alors on a parlé sport va maintenant
parler un tout autre sujet qu'il faut
trouver la transition va parler de
coopération franco allemande il ya
cinquante ans le traité de l'élysée
c'est un traité pour renforcer justement
la coopération entre ces deux pays a eu
lieu et il ya eu un colloque la semaine
dernière à versailles pour justement
célébrer ses 50 ans on va en parler dans
quelques instants avec notre invité
romy strasbourg john prononce ou oui
voilà oui c'est 20 donc je le prends
dans ce rapide vous a permis ça va être
plus simple
voilà vous prononcerez votre nuque
peut-être correspondante pour la presse
allemande mais d'abord retour sur ce
colloque colloque parlons avec un invité
d'honneur alain juppé ancien ministre
des affaires étrangères
le traité de l'élysée a été signé en
janvier 63 un traité pour sceller les
liens entre la france et l'allemagne est
fixé des objectifs de coopération
cinquante ans plus tard le sujet en
pleine crise européenne est plus que
d'actualité
d'où ces premières rencontres franco
allemande qui se sont déroulés ce
mercredi à versailles fallait à tout
prix avoir un événement en ile de france
ce n'est pas le cas il ya eu un
événement à sarrebruck qui a eu un
événement acte râble de reims il y en
aura la semaine prochaine à ludwigsburg
kiêu
le général de gaulle a fait son discours
à la jeunesse allemande en allemand en
62 il nous fallait un événement sur
paris et versailles s'y prêtait
parfaitement bien versailles est une île
chargé d'histoire dans la région franco
allemand et vous avez un aspect
historique dramatique on le sait bien
sûr 219 le traité de versailles où les
allemands finalement sont acculés à
cette capitulation des experts du monde
économique universitaire étaient
présents pour échanger autour d'un
invité d'honneur alain juppé l'ancien
ministre des affaires étrangères
trouvent une signification toute
politique à ces rencontres
la relation franco allemand n'est plus
que jamais une responsabilité historique
dans une europe dont on va bien
aujourd'hui les turbulences de ces
échanges doivent déboucher de nouveaux
projets de coopération qui seront
présentées au président français et la
chancelière allemande
un colloque surtout ouvert aux plus
jeunes cela n'est pas anodin
le département compte un établissement
franco-allemand à buc et alice et
international à saint germain en laye
voilà qui nous a rejoint sur ce plateau
pour parler de coopération franco
allemande jana soudry bonsoir vous étiez
à ce colloque tout elle fait il y avait
rencontré olivier breton qui est le
directeur du magazine paris berlin
nous on fait un petit plateau avec lui
nous explique un petit peu l'origine de
cette rencontre organisée à versailles
pour la première fois pour le couteau
nous sommes ici devant l'hôtel de ville
de versailles à l'occasion des premières
rencontres franco-allemandes pour les 50
ans du traité de l'élysée je suis à côté
d'olivier breton bonjour bonjour vous
êtes le directeur du magazine et du club
paris berlin
alors c'est aussi une première pourquoi
avoir décidé d'organiser ces journées
parce que il nous semblait que dans le
cadre des commémorations du traité de
l'élysée il fallait à tout prix avoir un
événement en ile de france ce n'est pas
le cas il ya eu un événement à
sarrebruck qui a eu un événement acte
râle de reims il y en aura la semaine
prochaine à ludwigsburg kiêu
le général de gaulle a fait son discours
jeunesse allemande en allemand en 62 il
nous fallait un événement sur paris et
versailles s'y prêtait parfaitement bien
quelles sont les personnes qui
participent à cette journée à ce
colloque exceptionnel
on a la chance d'avoir des gens aussi
connu quatre aides grosser dominique
wolton francis mer michel ans frôlent
olivier homolle enfin certain nombre
d'experts de monde de l'économie du
monde politique et du monde de
l'université et on attend là monsieur
juppé sur le parvis de l'hôtel de ville
quels sont les objectifs d'une telle
rencontre uniquement essayé de donner
sens et profondeur la relation franco
allemande que nous on préfère appeler
france allemagne
l'intérêt de faire à versailles un tel
événement c'est qu'on arrive à fédérer
des sections internationales aux délices
et franco-allemand que les yvelines sont
assez riches en la matière avec eux buts
avec saint germain en laye sèvres qui
n'est pas très loin c'est un coût qui
n'est pas très très loin 78 92 concentre
un certain nombre de jeunes qui sont des
sections internationales et qui sont
tout à fait sensibilisés aux
problématiques qu'on traite ici
justement les enjeux ne sont pas les
mêmes qu'il ya 50 ans surtout avec la
crise qu'on connaît actuellement cette
importance a aussi peut-être regarder
les choses d'une autre façon
alors clairement on est dans une autre
époque complètement nous on n'aime pas
trop le terme de commémoration dans
lequel se trouve mort la racine morts on
est beaucoup plus dans la réinvention
dans l'invention d'un projet nouveau on
pense que la réconciliation et le
travail remarquable qui a été menée par
nos grands aînés adenauer et de volants
tête mais après l'ensemble des
dirigeants des deux états ont fait ce
travail de réconciliation qui était
quand même absolument incroyable et
absolument inenvisageable il ya encore
50 ans aujourd'hui ce travail est fait
et les jeunes sont plutôt en demande
d'un nouveau projet d'un nouveau projet
européen et il cherchait de feuille de
route
nous on est là pour essayer de dresser
une feuille de route qu'on adressera à
l'issue de cette manifestation
aussi bien la chancelière merkel
coprésidera hollande
merci beaucoup olivier breton merci
aller retour en plateau avec vous hormis
strasburg ça va mieux tout à leur stress
pour avec m
j'ai pas dis strasbourg vous êtes
correspondante de presse pour la presse
allemande vous êtes aussi journaliste
pour le magazine de parle paris-berlin
vous avez participé à ce colloque
pourquoi c'était vraiment si important
les 50 ans de ce traité de l'elysée
c'est important d'en parler et je pense
que c'était tout simplement pour nous
qui sent tous les jours dans le
franco-allemand
encore une fois un événement qui nous a
montré que c'est c'est pas démodé c'est
toujours de l'actualité c'est important
et ça attire du monde et c'est ça qui
nous a rendus très heureux je pense tout
le monde qui a participé qu' il y avait
des gens en portant si je peux aider de
faire ça donc des gens qui en fait
qu'ils sont des figures des personnages
politiques et qui remettait à quel point
on a des choses à faire mais on a aussi
deux là qui est un peu ce peut être fier
de ce qu'on a fait pendant cinq ans on
peut effectivement être fier de ce qu'on
a fait en 50 ans parce que si on se
rappelle des traités précédents ou en
euro l'allemagne était quand même
voilà bien un petit peu écrasé
l'allemagne a réussi à ressortir et la
france est maintenant réussissent à
parler normalement on a du mal à lorient
c'est pas à bosser palau entre le fait
on a du mal à s'y rend plus que je viens
de l'allemagne de l'est donc il me
manque encore 20 ans j'ai que 20 ans
pour 7
traiter mais c'est vrai qu'à l'époque il
faut s'imaginer que c'était inimaginable
de pays comme sa grand pays en europe
qui sortait justement d'une guerre
terrible et qu'ils ont réussi à se
mettre ensemble et à crier quelque chose
avec ce contrat sur noir sur blanc pour
ray conseiller les deux pays mais pas
uniquement au niveau politique parce que
donc voilà il y avait des chefs d'état
qui est effectivement en plus c'était
des personnages très fort de gaulle et
adenauer
mais en plus de ça ce traité a quand
même créé des bases sur plusieurs
échelles comme aussi la culture on le
sait il y avait plein de choses qui ont
suivi pour la jeunesse avec
effectivement l'office franco allemand
pour la jeunesse on en parlera tout à
l'heure qui est qui s'est beaucoup
investi pour rapprocher les deux peuples
et je pense que l'on regarde aujourd'hui
il ya beaucoup de gens qui disent oh
mais non il ya encore il ya des choses
ça marche pas le moteur et les tonga je
vais vous poser ce qui a encore des
choses à faire parce qu'on connaît
vraiment ce couple franco-allemand qui
est moteur meneur là on regarde en
arrière on dit que par rapport à tous
les autres pays d'europe
voilà et c'est comme un peu l'exemple
alors qu'est ce qu'il reste à faire
effectivement en fait moi je fais partie
des médias qui se jette surtout sur ce
qui marche parce que ces métiers et
alors technos qui marche et 10 pouces et
bien marché pour le futur parce que dans
le reportage effectivement il était dit
que concrètement il ya avant des
propositions concrètes il y avait tout
fait au président landais à la
chancelière merkel tout à fait tu as
fait de rencontres d'ailleurs dimanche
prochain mais ils seront entre tristan
et c'est bien il ya des gens qui ont
tendance à dire que s'il se voit aussi
souvent c'est à dire qu'il ya des choses
qui marchent pas on peut dire aussi le
contraire en attendant ce que je disais
tout à l'heure de voir toujours le verre
à moitié vide mais moi j'essaie quand
même de voir des choses qui se passent
et qui font avancer avec si on compare
avec d'autres pays
prenant la chine le japon comme disait
le le dessinateur dessinateur plantu qui
était présent au colloque et qui a créé
sage super joli sac pour ben ali voilà
voilà voilà un joli l'amitié franco
allemande
il disait effectivement s'il il faut
s'imaginer un contrat d'elysée en
traiter d'elysée entre israël et la
palestine
aujourd'hui est que dans cinquante ans
il ya une normalité comme enlevant jeudi
mais j'aime or pour répondre à la
question de johan alors qu'on fera des
d'affaires qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
encore de plus je pense quand on vient
surtout avec paris berlin avec le
magazine aussi sur un niveau européen
pour dire que les relations franco
allemandes
le moteur franco allemand c'est très
bien mais il faut qu'il sert en tant
qu'exemple pour toute l'europe et qui
hilton en fait des initiatives qui
montre qu est ce qui peut marcher et que
les autres pays peuvent aussi se dire ah
tiens c'est un marché pour l'allemagne
et la france et donc la perspective de
paris berlin c'est toujours de ne pas
rester sur le grand discours politique
langue du bois en disant ouais tout le
monde est beau tout le monde il est
gentil mais effectivement de proposer
des choses et c'est ce qu'ils ont fait
après le fameux colloque entend tant
parler tout à l'heure qui qui a qui a
été composée par plusieurs ateliers de
travail avec tes sujets alors vraiment
qu'est ce qu'il en est sortie de crise
en se disant en fait ça te ferait ça
c'était de ses amis ils ont rédigé une
lettre à la chancelière et au président
français je peux pas tout vous dévoiler
parce que c'est en train de sa va partir
ce soir là les couples ainsi faisant
bonne énorme scoop énorme et surtout
donc on va pas tout vous dire mais je
vous dis quand même quelques quelques
exemples ça parlera de la mobilité
éducatif et professionnel entre la
france et allemagne est parce que il y a
des choses qui sont à améliorer ça parle
pas ça parlera également des des besoins
du marché du travail ça parlera de la
politique de sécurité et de défense
d'énergie commune donc il ya des
propositions concrètes mais il ya aussi
dans dans les propositions quelque chose
qui vise plus sur une vision un rêve
parce que en fait moi je le sais très
bien parce que j'ai rêvé pendant
longtemps de vivre un moment de ma vie
passer un moment de ma vie en france
il faut toujours un rêve c'est ça qui
motive les gens c'est ça qui les
intrigue le rêve peut peut-être passé
par là je n'ai la wii je me tourne vers
vous jouanna parce qu'effectivement elle
a été fortement question l'occasion de
ce colloque l'armée lyons de la jeunesse
la coopération franco allemand entendu
tout à l'heure olivier breton le
directeur du magazine paris-berlin
évoqué la jeunesse franco allemande
c'est dans cette dynamique a été créée
directement après le traité de l'élysée
l'office franco allemand pour la
jeunesse à plélauff âge dont vous
parliez à l'instant il est chargé de
développer les relations entre la
jeunesse française et la jeunesse
allemande et depuis 1963 et bien l'ofas
a permis à plus de vies millions de
jeunes français et allemands de
participer à près de 300000 programme
des changes s'est beaucoup 1 3 me la met
concrètement c'est quoi ce programme des
changes
alors concrètement l ofaj dont le siège
se situe à paris a mis en place des
missions éducatives et culturelles
il met à disposition des jeunes des
bourses des bourses financières pour
justement des cours de langue des cours
de langue allemande bien sûr il propose
des formations professionnelles des
programmes d'échangés scolaires ou
extrascolaires nos preuves et les jeunes
tôlerie et à berlin
c'est moitié moitié oui voilà et donc je
me tourne vers vous parce que vous
m'avez dit que l'oph h vous connaissiez
bien
ah bah oui ils nous connaissent je les
connais bien j'ai un pur produit jeudi
je suis un enfant de l'oph âge en petit
peu parce que effectivement il ment
soutenu dans mon parcours professionnel
vos premières stage que j'ai fait dans
un journal régional à nancy l'est
républicain a été financé en partie
grâce à l'oph âge donc les frais de
voyage et donc moi je n'avais pas
forcément besoin d'un cours de l'un
parce que je faisais des études de
français mais ils soutiennent des gens à
plusieurs niveaux et surtout du bol en
allemagne sont des jeunes allemands
revenir en france l'eau fonctionne à la
fin j'ai aussi d'autres créations tout à
fait vraiment tout près de nous le lycée
franco-allemand qui est a vu que c'est
le seul français il ya deux autres lycée
franco-allemand qui existe en allemagne
à sarrebruck et berlin spécificités de
ces établissements et des offres deux
sections élèves allemands et français
sont accueillis et se prépare à un
unique diplôme le baccalauréat franco
allemand reconnu bien sûr dans les deux
pays et donc c'est un établissement qui
n'est pas réservée en famille franco
allemande puisque on peut entrer pour
les français sur concours
c'est une filière d'excellence qui
donc 870 élèves c'est à dire un tiers
d'élèves sont allemands deux tiers
français à peu près et pour les
professeurs c'est pareil avec 90
professeurs tous merci jona pour ce
président encore pu en parler longtemps
de la coopération franco merci en tout
cas n'en ferons demain mais je voulais
que délégué aux pme l'innovation
d'économie numérique fleur pellerin qui
a réalisé sa scolarité au
franco-allemand à buc
voilà bah oui mais je tenais surtout de
bagages un numéro de paris berlin parce
que c'est la cible initialement merci
aux conneries sur le plateau ses 7,8 de
lundi est terminée demain sur le plateau
de cette fuite nous en serons notamment
nantais nakata de retour des jo de
londres et sera également question de la
twizy le véhicule électrique renault a
lancé en autopartage à saint quentin à
partir de demain d'ici là excellente
soirée et a donc à demain